ينصه ميثاق الامم المتحده على ان الاعضاء
الذين تساوي متاخراتهم مبالغ مساهماتهم عن
العامين السابقين كاملين او تزيد عن ذلك
يفقدون حقوقهم في التصويت ولكنه يمنح
الجمعيه العامه ايضا سلطه تقرير لان عدم
الدفع يرجع الى ظروف خارج عن اراده العضو
وفي هذه الحاله يمكن لاي بلد ان يستمر في
التصويت
فنزويلا ولبنان وجنوب السودان من بين ست
دول فقدت حقوقها في التصويت في الجمعيه
العامه المكونه من 130
والسبب هو تاخرها عن سداد مستحقاته
ميزانيه تشغيل الامم المتحده
الامين العام للامم المتحده
الذكر في بيان ان الدول الثلاثه الاخرى
التي فقدت حق التصويت هي الدومينيكا غينيا
الاستوائيه غابون كما قررت الجمعيه العامه
ان الثلاثه دول اخرى من القاره الافريقيه
هي جزر القمر والصوت وبرين سبي والصومال
مدرجه على قائمه الدول التي عليها متاخرات
لكنها ستكون قادره على الاحتفاظ بحقوقها
في التصويت اما الحد الادنى من المدفوعات
اللازمه لاستعاره حقوق التصوير فهو 76
مليون دولار الى فنزويلا وما يناهز
مليونير دولار للبنان و 619 الف دولار الى
غينيا الاستوائيه ونحو المئتين الف دولار
لجنوب السودان و 61,000 دولار للجابون
وعشرون الف دولار للدومينيكان